[Music]
hello there standing and doing nothing
in a game is something we rarely do yet
more often than not it's the only way to
see a rare animation a secret and
sometimes an Easter egg
today we are going AFK in 20 video games
to see what happens like leaving grogu
too long in Lego Star Wars he'll
eventually start eating the wildlife
just like he did in the Mandalorian
probably the most iconic AFK animation
has to be Sonic the Hedgehog and his
tapping foot that animation is so well
known it made it into the movie but
Sonic CD did something to change this if
our blue Hedgehog is left idle for too
long he'll straight up Yeet himself into
Oblivion and things get worse because it
doesn't take away a single life it takes
away all of them game over Mario has had
many Idol animations over the years but
Mario Odyssey must be the best after
standing idle for too long Mario will
sit and eventually take a nap and a bird
will pert on his nose but did you know
in each world or biome he visits a
different bird will come and land on his
snout my personal favorite is the Hat
Kingdom just look at this little leg end
or maybe the best one is the Penguin
can't decide which is best sometimes
standing still can result in unique
audio in WWE 2k23 if both players refuse
to fight the commentators can get a
little frustrated I'm calling for a
disqualification on account of boredom
at this point things that you'd rather
be doing than sitting here watching
these two I'd rather be stuck in traffic
[Applause]
[Music]
Donkey Kong Country Tropical Freeze
Banjo-Kazooie and Astros playroom all
share an AFK animation standing around
long enough and all three will whip out
their portable gaming devices Donkey
Kong has a Nintendo DS Banjo-Kazooie has
an OG Game Boy and I think astrobot has
a Vita or is that a PSP Astro likes to
multitask too he can sometimes be seen
using psvr IF unattended offering rage
is a great Easter egg stands still long
enough while holding rocket launcher and
this happens a teeny tiny screen begins
to play Doom insane I love it again you
shouldn't AFK in is Gang Beasts
especially on water levels for example
at the aquarium an octopus will become
very annoyed if you refuse to get
involved with the action expect a
tentacle to come your way and pull
inactive players into the void
whereas on ocean-based levels AFK
players will find this happens
[Music]
sometimes standing still long enough can
lead to in-game Trophies or special
cutscenes in Far Cry 4 we go to dinner
with the game's big bad guy right at the
start of the game don't move I will be
right back when he steps out for a
moment we are supposed to run away and
the game starts for real yet by sitting
still and doing absolutely nothing at
all he'll eventually return fan bloody
you sir are a gentleman and a secret
ending will play as somehow this bad guy
has become our father figure it's a
surprising ending but it's Canon to me
back when Uncharted 4 was being revealed
at E3 The Depths had a massive failure
as Nathan Drake refused to move at all
millions of people watched as he just
stood still naughty dog then turned that
embarrassment into a hidden trophy in
the final release of the game by
standing idle at the same spot as the
devs you'd be gifted the stage fright
trophy literally a trophy for doing
nothing at all doing absolutely nothing
in Hogwarts Legacy he reveals countless
secret animations on the character
select screen simply resist touching the
controller and your dorm room will come
alive depending on your progress in the
game you'll experience randomized
encounters from a niffler escaping your
bag in the pursuit of gold maybe a
phoenix will perch in the background and
even the golden snitch from quidditch
will make an appearance there are so
many more including the beasts you've
tamed over the course of the game and
even your house elf will turn up too
hopefully he's in a good mood another
game to do this is Deadpool the Merc
with a mouth can be seen having a
scratch
wait around long enough and he'll start
cosplaying in other outfits like x-foss
a track suit a maid and even this pseudo
X-Men outfit keep your digits away from
the keyboard or controller and
eventually he'll talk directly to you
just wondered you got any girls in there
back to Lego Star Wars and every single
character has multiple idle animations
one in particular is really impressive
take a look at Anakin's his lightsaber
can malfunction turning the blue of the
Jedi into the red of the Sith
foreshadowing his journey to the dark
side I don't think anyone noticed you're
okay bro another Star Wars game is Jedi
Survivor and our hero calkestis has a
bunch of AFK details but there's one
which is more epic than all the others
very occasionally he'll use the force to
break apart his own lightsaber just to
pass the time no one likes a Jedi who
shows off Gamers usually know how to
follow instructions but have you ever
been tempted to just do the opposite of
what you're told in God of War Ragnarok
while playing as atreyus we are asked to
leave the room and of course we need to
know what happens if we just stand still
maybe if we just stare at him and say
nothing he'll get the hint and leave
this game also lets you listen in at the
door it doesn't get much better I'm not
joking son go well now this is just
getting weird the best Idol animations
add to the characters on screen take
Sia's rare animation in Apex Legends
lobbies a fan will approach and ask for
an autograph and Sia is more than happy
to make their day
oh he's so happy over in Hong Kai star
rail keep off your controller for a
minute when playing as one of these two
characters and they will attempt to sing
one is very good
[Laughter]
but now listen to this guy
yikes it's not great but it's an a for
effort SpongeBob games are packed with
great Idol animations my man can imitate
a chicken he can put his finger through
his head and he can even twerk a little
on the old PSP game SpongeBob hated
waiting for someone to lift the
controller and over time would Age grow
out a long beard take up a walking stick
and a road into ashes leaving only a
skeleton behind SpongeBob does not like
waiting in more modern games Mr
SquarePants has found new ways to amuse
himself like this I honestly have no
idea what's going on here did you know
that link can visit the restroom in
Skyward Sword there's more it's also
possible to leave him there long enough
that he falls asleep on the loo luckily
he wakes up just in time to stop a
spillage because that's what Heroes do
Conker's Bad Fur Day is a game with some
mature themes even though it looks
perfect for children yeah but my butt be
careful not to leave him on a company it
for too long as his innocent juggling
and video gaming suddenly becomes a
makeshift flamethrower and a magazine
about beavers if you don't get that joke
be sure to ask your dad about his
favorite Beaver high on life is a great
first person shooter that makes fun of
video game tropes and to really stand
out from the crowd it breaks the fourth
wall constantly like this if you don't
press any inputs for long enough your
gun will start talking to you through
the TV so uh how's it going I'm talking
to you the the person the human playing
the game not the fictional character
holding me I'm talking to you through
the screen say something back it's gonna
blow your mind I'll be able to hear you
I promise it's crazy crazy and finally
something huge to end how many years has
Tom been chasing Jerry around ever since
1940. in that time Tom has never really
caught that Mouse for very long and now
in multiverses that war continues and it
finally happened to catch Jerry all Tom
needed to do was go AFK don't press any
input and it's that simple he'll pick up
that annoying rodent so sometimes going
AFK is a good thing I'm Adam you're
awesome thanks for sticking around till
the end mwah see you next time